you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
the cop 26 president alok sharma warns
world leaders are some way from
consensus and that getting over the line
will prove a challenge
rich nations edged towards the 100
billion pledge to help developing
countries but the former bank of england
governor mark carney tells us 100
trillion will be needed over the next
two decades
a petition is submitted to the
international criminal court accusing
brazil's president bolsonaro of crimes
against humanity over the deforestation
of the amazon
and warming warning what buckingham
palace could look like if the planet
warms by three degrees
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
there are now just 20 days to go until
the cop 26 summit begins and today its
president delivered a sobering message
and a rallying call speaking in paris
alok sharma admitted that any agreement
was still some way off and he called on
every country to play its part in
glasgow insisting that the world will
succeed or fail as one
in london milan we saw progress
but we are still
some way off consensus
and i want to be frank
it will be a challenging task to get us
over the line
so as i said to ministers in italy we
must all come to cop armed with the
currency of compromise
because the world will not understand if
six years on we still cannot reach
agreement on these issues in glasgow
there was more positive news from mr
sharma when he revealed that richer
nations were edging towards finally
fulfilling the 100 billion a year pledge
to help developing nations cope with the
effects of climate change
he also addressed what comes next in
terms of financing a greener future
the paris agreement set us on a path to
transform all global financial flows to
deliver a green and sustainable economy
so as well as delivering public finance
we need to unleash trillions of dollars
of private finance to transition to a
greener world
and i'm pleased to see the success of
the glasgow financial lines for net zero
led by mark carney and others this now
represents over 90 trillion dollars in
assets it's an enormous achievement
the next step
is to ensure that some of this money is
channeled into developing countries to
scale up green resilient infrastructure
well you heard mr sharma mention mark
carney there and today the former bank
of england governor who's now back in
canada was interviewed for sky news's
big ideas live the first of a series of
in-person events focusing on business
and the economy as the uk emerges from
the pandemic he told the audience in
rotherham just how huge the scale of the
finance needed will be in the future
the first thing to say is for anyone
coming to this new or not following a
day-to-day the numbers are absolutely
enormous so um what you're asking about
is as you know a hundred billion dollars
a year this was a pledge of
the rich countries basically to help the
poorer countries developing economies
with the transition it was made 10 years
ago in copenhagen and we haven't met it
yet and it's one of the key objectives
for the uk for this for glasgow for cop
is to get to that number
it's very important but at the same time
and i apologize to your audience
just to put it in context we need to
multiply that by a thousand
in terms of additional
capital additional finance in other
words we need not just a hundred billion
dollars we need a hundred trillion
dollars over the next uh two decades two
and a half decades in order to get to
where we need to go and the point that
we've recognized very early on is that's
only going to come from the private
sector
well mr carney was speaking to my
colleague samantha washington he told us
what else she'd asked him about
the credibility of government's
commitment here is so important to get
that money flowing so i wanted to ask
the former governor of the bank of
england of course knows all the nuts and
bolts of the uk economy is also an
advisor to the prime minister on cop 26
about what he thought about something
going on a little closer to home and
that is the inquiry into whether or not
to open a coal mine in cumbria or indeed
embark on oil and gas exploration in
cambo sands
i think it is helpful that an inquiry is
being done into this and independent
inquiry is being done to this because it
shows exactly what the issues are around
the transition uh let's take the example
of the uh of the coal uh mine in cumbria
which is coal being used for steel not
coal being used for power generation but
still has an environmental impact if
it's done uh there is a gap between um
the life of that coal mine it could run
until 2050 effectively uh the life of
that coal mine and what
our trajectory needs to be in the uk in
order to get to net zero a coal mine
like that really can only run in the
judgment of that independent panel until
2035 so what it does this approach is it
shines a light on
how we need to change and it forces us
to think much more carefully about
putting in place new investments in
carbon intensive sectors
and much greater intention
focus on transitioning from you know the
old economy to the new economy in a way
that's growing our growing jobs and uh
and incomes
climate science is telling us that the
emergency is accelerating we've only got
a couple of weeks until this conference
takes place and is very much at stake
here we don't even know whether some of
the big players china australia to name
a few are even going to be there but the
stakes could not be higher
in some of today's other climate news
chinese president xi jinping has
launched a new fund to help developing
nations protect their biodiversity and
benefit from a greener economy
she made the announcement at the cop 15
biodiversity summit in china where
diplomats scientists and
conservationists are attempting to
create a global agreement to reverse the
destruction of nature the summit was
launched by prince charles who warned
that humanity is bringing devastation
upon itself by not respecting and
protecting nature
the well-being and livelihoods of future
generations depend on us preserving the
biodiversity that still exists
that is why rapidly protecting at least
30 percent of our planet's natural
ecosystems on land and in the oceans
by 2030 is absolutely critical
so too is addressing the overwhelming
burden
but a growing global population places
on nature and its ability to sustain us
new research has identified which places
could be wiped out or saved depending on
what climate action the world takes
images modeled by climate central show
what impact rising sea levels could have
on iconic locations
under a best-case scenario temperatures
would rise by 1.5 degrees and water
could reach the entrance of buckingham
palace
under a three degrees warming scenario
the palace is flooded up to the second
floor these are of course extreme
predictions which don't take into
account future flood prevention measures
operators of the world's largest storm
surge barrier have warned even it won't
be able to cope with rising sea levels
predicted over the next 50 years the
mars land barrier in rotterdam in the
netherlands automatically closes when a
storm warning is triggered
its huge steel structure sinking to the
bottom of the harbour and forming a
giant seal
eighty-five percent of the city lies
below sea level making it particularly
vulnerable to flooding
the brazilian president jaya bolsonaro
has been accused of crimes against
humanity over his actions in the amazon
in an official complaint lodged at the
international criminal court in the
hague the environmental law organization
all rise filed the complaint seeking
legal proceedings against mr bolsonaro
and his administration for actions it
claims are directly connected to the
negative impacts of climate change
around the world
well i spoke a little earlier to rupert
a doctoral researcher in climate science
and co-founder of the oxford sustainable
law program who helped compile the
scientific case he began by telling me
what effect amazonian deforestation has
had on brazil and the rest of the world
globally deforestation is the second
biggest contributor to climate change
after burning of fossil fuels and the
impact of deforestation in the brazilian
amazon which is accelerating in the last
few years under the presidency of gyara
bosnaro
are substantial globally deforestation
has impact humanitarian impacts around
the world through climate change and
through the later scientific governments
we're able to demonstrate those causal
links
so why does deforestation cause climate
change
deforestation causes the release of
large amounts of carbon dioxide
emissions and as
atmospheric carbon dioxide levels
increase we get global warming and
global warming manifests in extreme
events occurring around the world with
increasing intensity increasingly
frequently as well as the rise in sea
levels for treated glaciers that affect
communities worldwide
and to what extent then is it on the
rise
um deforestation in the brazilian amazon
was
at relatively stable levels for the
decades prior to the election of mr
bostner
in the last two and a half years we've
seen a substantial acceleration um 34
above 2018 levels in 2019 and 44 above
2018 levels in 2020. so
these rates are accelerating at the same
time as they really need to be
decreasing if we are to meet the goals
of the paris agreement we need to
eliminate deforestation altogether by
2030 but that's not what's happening
it's going unfortunately in the wrong
direction the brazilian government
hasn't uh yet issued a response to this
legal action but no doubt it would point
out that it's launched a crackdown on
environmental criminals in the amazon it
would also point out that its
environment minister has said that
brazil's really keen to demonstrate at
cop26 that it could be part of the
solution to climate change and also that
it's committed to cutting emissions
commitments to climate change um
ultimately have to be credible they have
to be followed through with action and
while
uh commitments to reduce deforestation
is actually absolutely what we need
that's not what the data says is
happening at the moment deforestation is
accelerating and the emissions resulting
from it are increasing substantially
and that is what causes humanitarian
consequences around the world
what's the best thing that can be done
about it what part can legal action play
in halting deforestation
the law has a vital role to play in
action to tackle climate change and
we've seen successful lawsuits
in germany the netherlands
ireland and elsewhere in the last few
years that have caused governments to be
required legally to increase ambition
and increase the enforcement of climate
policy
so
where
legislation is falling short the law can
play a vital role in
in ensuring that meaningful action on
climate change is taken
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by dr shihu from
the labor and work life program at
harvard law school and senior associate
at the energy and climate intelligence
unit and environmental consultant
richard blacker standing by ready and
waiting and we're going to be discussing
the role of biodiversity in the fight
against climate change and if climate
lawsuits can do more harm than good
i think it's an important moment for
the g20 a group of
economically rich countries and
politically influential countries to get
together and to a large extent get
beyond the emotion associated with the
way in which things fell apart in
afghanistan just two months ago and to
focus on some of the key issues which
confront all of us whether we like it or
not
and those include fight against terror
and ironically we're going to have to
engage with the taliban because at the
moment they are
the only power on the ground in
afghanistan who can confront
isis
it's going to include a conversation i
hope about rights in particular of women
and about
aid and engaging to support the
population there but the taliban have
not been invited to the table and i
think that would have been very unusual
and i would never have expected it but i
think that what uh all the leaders of
the g20 need to recognize now is that
without actually stating that the
taliban is a legitimate uh
government per se
for operational reasons there is uh
every need to engage with the taliban on
a day-to-day basis and i think
increasingly now that's starting to
happen and and that is a good thing if
indeed
uh the united kingdom and other
countries wish to stay engaged in a very
important part of the world remember
that afghanistan is just south of russia
just west of china east of iran and
north of pakistan and india so this is a
crucial part of the world and the uk and
other countries in the west certainly
want to stay engaged
well i dealt with the taliban for over
three years on a very regular basis both
outside the country uh and inside the
country and um i have to say
it and this may sound unusual but it's
it's um a group with whom one can have a
conversation and where there is a
certain amount of clarity i am not
surprised by some of the measures that
the taliban are taking at the moment
including preventing
uh teenage girls from attending school
this is something that none of us want
to see
but we need to engage in a conversation
with the taliban on that type of an
issue and if we stay away we can't
[Music]
do
did you know if more of us walked roll
bikes and scoots to school we would make
a big difference to the air pollution
around our school yeah like us
there'll be a chilly start for some on
wednesday with a grass frost possible in
parts of eastern england
early low cloud and fog will slowly lift
to leave sunny spells for many thicker
clouds over parts of southern and
western britain will be stubborn to
clear giving some patchy light rain in
places
that rain will become increasingly
confined to the northwest during the
afternoon
we've got clean atlantic air moving in
on the westerly flow so the air
pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will
stay low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with dr
cece hu program fellow of the labor and
work life programme at harvard law
school and senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit and
environmental consultant richard black
so good to see you both welcome welcome
so ahead of cop 26 which we've heard
about on this and most other editions of
our show there's another big un
conference taking place cop 15 on
biodiversity is hosted by china and is
taking place virtually now world leaders
are discussing how to protect and slow
the loss of nature
it's widely believed that climate change
is a primary driver for biodiversity
loss so how important is it that we
tackle the two issues together cece i'll
put that to you
first of all what is the link between
biodiversity and climate change and does
it make sense to you that they're dealt
with together
um thank you for having me um so
biodiversity is closely linked to
climate change in two ways number one
that climate change um reduces
biodiversity and this is because um
temperature rises are now means that
plants and animals are struggling to
survive and the second way in which like
climate change is linked to biodiversity
is that biodiversity acts as a mitigator
for climate change so essentially
biodiversity means more plants and these
plants suck up emissions like a vacuum
cleaner in essence so
they help mitigate the climate crisis so
that's those are the sort of linkages
so so richard important that countries
with less money are helped to try and
protect their biodiversity and we have
heard haven't we that china's pledged a
230 million dollars for a new
biodiversity fund did that surprise you
that move
not particularly because i think china
is very keen to make a success of this
in terms of the amount of money it is
really a drop in the ocean though i
covered when i was a journalist 10 years
ago the last really big biodiversity
summit in in japan at that stage the sum
of money that were being talked about to
basically halt the global loss of
biodiversity is about 100 billion
dollars a year so we're somewhere short
of this but a very very long way short
of this um i think it doesn't it does um
raise an interesting point because in
the climate change arena the
international agreements basically
specify that all the money that helps
the developing countries has to come
from the traditionally rich nations from
europe and north america and australia
and japan and so on so by china putting
this forward we may be you know seeing
the the the start of a discussion about
whether some of the newly enriching
nations china saudi arabia qatar some of
the others actually should be putting
their hands in their pockets also for
climate change damages well yes and on
that subject of climate finance cc
there's been a big debate about
why the money hasn't been forthcoming
quickly enough i mean is there enough
money going towards biodiversity or is
it seen as the poor relation somehow
yeah i think money is um is very
important and um there needs to be more
um but i really think the issue here is
um in terms of our diversity and climate
change is that we do not we have not
really linked human activities with
biodiversity and by that i mean that
basically human activities are the key
drivers to biodiversity loss but we
don't really know exactly how our
investment decisions or business
decisions or actually having a proper
outcome on biodiversity so um i would
like to highlight a
wayside in which that we can make that
link and one example is a eu regulation
which is called the eu taxonomy
regulation act which was brought in last
year but basically what they do is that
they link economic activities with um
proper
biodiversity outcomes so if you're an
investor if you're business people you
are going to you know invest in a place
where there is biodiversity problems you
wouldn't know so this is the kind of
mechanism that we need um in developing
countries to really help them with the
decision-making process in addition to
financial
support okay let's move on to our second
topic now because the number of lawsuits
over climate change has more than
doubled over the last six years as
environmental groups use courts to
pressure governments and companies to
act and there have been some notable
successes in 2019 the dutch supreme
court ruled in favor of climate
activists who demanded action from the
government more recently gas company
shell was ordered to cut its worldwide
emissions by 45 in the next decade but
what happens when environmentalists lose
and does it cause more harm than good
richard to you first of all
how effective is a tool
a tool is litigation
in tackling climate change there has
been a rise in lawsuits around the world
haven't there i think 1 896 cases have
been filed but
do many of them actually make a
difference
i think very few of them actually make a
difference in terms of reducing
emissions i think the two that you
mentioned there
by far the two standouts um
cases here they can also make a
difference in other ways of course by
creating publicity creating awareness
shining a light on on what's going on we
we've just had a court a case for
example in scotland about proposed new
oil development which which lost but
nevertheless has helped escalate the
issue up the agenda i think at other
times though if the badly judged case
can do more harm than good for a number
of reasons one is that if you get a
court ruling against you saying that a
project you're opposing is legal well
then you have it now from the judges
that it is legal so you kind of lost
that one and the developers have
something to fall back on that they
didn't have before at times it can also
be a bit divisive and in the case of mr
bolsonaro i'm not sure anything is
really going to work with him part of
his political persona is that he's
defending uh ordinary brazilians
interests against the outside world that
wants to tell brazil what to do so it's
hard to see that even if he loses this
particular one would have a vast amount
of impact city what do you think do you
think the fact that action is taken
against an individual against the
company against the government even if
it's not successful it has some benefit
because it raises awareness what's your
take on it
yeah i i have to agree with richard
again here um i think it is very
important that we use litigation as a
tool to raise awareness um but i don't
think we can just rely on litigation as
a solution because these processes take
a long time to to you know conclude and
they involve a lot of people um but so
they need to be coupled with other uh
tools um but what i would say is that i
think we need to do a lot more research
on how litigation actually impacts
environmental climate outcomes um that
you know it's it's about how
which litigation measures actually was
effective in reducing a certain amount
of admissions or which ones were not so
we can have a learning
session on how how best to design
litigative measures um in order to
achieve the outcomes that we want
richard very briefly that is a point
takes a long time doesn't it and
everyone keeps saying we haven't got
very much time to to to sort this out
we haven't got much time yeah i think
ccc made an extremely good point
yeah i think [ __ ] made an extremely
good point there um
court cases do take action on the other
hand when they come out well like the
agenda one in holland you get very quick
actions so like cece said i'm going to
agree with her totally
learn the lessons make the cool make
smart
pursue smart litigation not on smart
litigation okay richard black cece who
always good to see you both thanks very
much indeed
do stay tuned here on sky news coming up
the damning report that describes the
government's handling of the covid
pandemic as one of the uk's worst ever
public health failures that's coming up
on sky news tonight i'll be back
tomorrow see you then
[Music]